on the mound tonight manning a more
confident manning on the mound utilizing
all of his pitches in his arsenal you'll
see him throw off speed pitches the
first pitch you'll see him command the
strike zone he has been attacking attack
and attacking look for manny to do
exactly that in tonight's ball game
that'll bring vladie guerrero to the
plate with a man on and one up
first pitch swinging and a line drive at
zach short to retire thank you very much
brings up the designated hitter tay
oscar hernandez now the 2-2
and he struck him out foul tipped it
into the glove of eric haas and a strong
start for matt manning on this friday
night
congratulations to miguel cabrera who
this past sunday in toronto became the
28th player in major league baseball
history to surpass 500 home runs in his
career
miguel cabrera is also the first player
ever to hit his 500th home run as a
detroit tiger white grows on health
daughter isabella and son christopher
for making the official change on the
mickey milestone home run counter in
left field
so let's hear it
one more time for the newest member of
the 500 home run club
miguel cabrera
start number 23 on the season for
stephen mats this is his first start at
comerica park
last time against detroit outstanding
again just gave up the one run that was
the 500th career home run to miguel
cabrera so romney grossman in left
fielder he's a switch hitter batting
right-handed against matt's he takes her
first pitch and winds it into right
field corey dickerson is back and makes
a nice play that's a tough play
dickerson is naturally a left fielder
and that was a totally different angle
as he gets the start in right two outs
on three pitches here in the first for
jamer candelario
fly ball deep left field that goes
guriel and that ball's off the wall
candelario digs for second he will
cruise in with a two-out double his 35th
double of the season that leads the
major
[Music]
how will leagues pitch to miguel cabrera
knowing that he surrendered his 500th
homer last sunday another one too
fly ball right field
that ball's deep that ball is
fouled
oh that had 502 written all over it but
it curled late
ground ball to third on the short hop
kevin smith it's a nice play tigers
strand
a candelario double and we are scoreless
after one
so it's second and third and toronto has
a couple in scoring position now manning
battles kevin smith
how about a pop-up will you take that
i'll take a pop-up
jonathan scopes under it he's got it
that's a big out one more to get and
that'll come in the form of reese
maguire
he struck him out
traffic
damage avoided matt manning will face
the top of the card both
breaking ball rolled down to third past
the reach of candelario and rippling up
the left field line getting deep into
the corner bow is racing around second
he's thinking about third but he powers
down and he'll stop with a lead off
double second straight inning for matt
manning with high leverage the one two
he rings him up third strikeout of the
night for matt manning and the second
one looking vladimir guerrero jr at the
plate one out bowed second lottie flares
went into the outfield and that's going
to drop bo is going to come around third
and he'll score
vladie guerrero is headed for second and
he'll get there
an rbi double for vladi he's seen two
pitches and he's hit them both and this
one is a double his 20 first double of
this season two outs for corey dickerson
half cut swing and a miss on a fastball
up and away strikeout number four for
matt manning and there are two away matt
manning could use a quick inning
although the pitch count isn't in any
type of danger
smith sends one to deep left center
field kill tracking it he's got it
that looked like it was over the wall
but nothing is safe in center field with
derek hill patrolling center field
jonathan scope jamer candelario now
miguel cabrera coming up against the
blue jays lefty stephen mats
that one hit matt and he's not gonna get
the first says oh my gosh
what a play by vlady guerrero guerrero
yeah you could smile on now but so could
steven matz they had no business making
that play it hit matt's in the foot he
was a little late breaking but then
vlady let him perfectly it's gonna be
another ground rule double for jamer
candelario and sets up an rbi chance for
miguel cabrera
right back up the middle base hits
candelario's being waved home
no throw we are tied
and that's exactly why miguel cabrera is
an rbi machine he hits to the situation
doesn't get big with this swing with the
runner at second base sneaking up the
middle gets him a fast ball over the
heart of the play and he whistles this
ball back up the middle now 41 hits shy
of 3 000 for miguel cabrera runners at
first and second with two away here's to
oscar and anderson for two so far ahead
in the count one two swung on and missed
that's a career high in strikeouts for
matt manning stephen mats and matt
manning locked up in a pitchers duel
ground ball in the middle of the diamond
flag down by the shed jump throw to
first in time boy boba's shed is moving
so much better defensively recently
phobic shift has been rock solid lately
it's short stop off balance throw
against his body throws it on the money
to retire grossman one out single for
scope candelario's got a couple of
doubles
he's moving a lot and that ball is hit
to flatty and there's a tag at second
and bill cosby calls out scope
boy what an interesting plane that was
yeah look at the smile on bladdy that's
one thing that never slumps that vladie
guerrero smile glad he got the ball
stepped on the bag and made a strong
throw to second and phil cousy the crew
chief was behind this play and
you know he calls him out but it was a
high tag and it looked like that left
foot might have got in there let's see
what the umpires say they say he's out
and the double play converted and the
tigers are out in the sixth adam simber
is on out of the bullpen for toronto
has his first hit is coming off the eye
out here's dez cameron
hey it gets by the first baseman
guerrero
haas can run
he's gonna go all the way to third
he'll put the brakes on there and the
blue jays do the tigers a bit of a favor
here in the seventh yeah and here's an
opportunity for das cameron to cash in
with the runner at third base less than
two outs situational hitting here where
you want to get yourself a piss that you
can handle infield is in right back to
the mound haas was going on contact had
to hustle back to third
and there are two away the ross is still
at third base but now there are two outs
[Music]
popped him up on the infield
bow will beat it and make a catch and
the inning is over the air does not
create a problem
victor reyes as the pinch hitter for
zach short reyes
and that one gets by a charging
palacios all the way to the wall
reyes all the way to third they're gonna
wave him home santiago puts the windmill
on reyes is
inside the park home run for victor
reyes
and yeah you would think well you want
to keep that ball in front of you but
it's an outfit you want to make plays
and he takes a chance
and he gets by him and reyes was off and
running it's a nice debut in the series
off the bench yes it was catch your
breath young man 55th appearance for
greg risotto in search of his 16th save
fly ball deep left field grossman's back
he leaps he's got it
exhale
pinch hitter santiago espinal down he
goes
gregory soto makes quick work of espinal
for two away randall grichik he'll pinch
it for valera
ground ball to third candelario long
throw they got him
and a nice way to kick start your
weekend
2-1 the final
tigers win it